[Music]
one okay hello can does that make any
difference fantastic good evening thank
you for coming as you all know because
the president of the United States the
Secretary of State the vice president
Prime Minister of Great Britain the
British Home Secretary and so many
others have told us so many times what
is happening in Iraq and Syria with this
group occupying a region larger than
Great Britain and calling itself the
Islamic state has nothing to do with
Islam and they are neither Islamic nor
State they have currency they have
passports they have the government they
have courts they have a legal system but
they are not a state and they say that
they pattern everything that they do
after the teachings of Islam and they
are not
Islamic white is black day is Night War
is peace freedom is slavery ignorance is
strength the fact of the matter is of
course that the Islamic state is in
Islamic indeed and is in fact
quintessentially Islamic but I'm not
asking you to take my word for it over
that of the president of the United
States Secretary of State the vice
president Prime Minister of Great
Britain the British Home Secretary and
every other authority in the world I'm
not asking you to take my word for it I
happen to have brought as I'm sure you
all did too the Quran tonight I don't
leave home without it
and this Quran is a uh a very nice
addition that I actually got a few years
back when uh I was in London I was in
London to film part of a documentary and
and I did I had a lot of free time and
so I did what any American Tourist would
do in London i t the local mosqu and I
got this Quran which I was assured was a
moderate Quran with moderate commentary
by say Abal mudi who was a Pakistani
politician and Scholar of Islam who died
in 1979 he's internationally influential
he's mainstream if you go into any
Islamic bookstore I'm sure you probably
got a coupon card in your local Islamic
bookstore and if you go in there you
will find books by mudi I guarantee it
100% And so this is a mainstream
moderate Quran I got it actually at the
Finsbury Park Mosque you may remember
Abu Hamza almasri Captain Hook he had
two hooks for hands because uh in an
excess of religious fervor he blew off
his hands in a bomb accident and he uh
was the Imam of the Finsbury Park Mosque
but then he was arrested for plotting
Jihad Terror activities he was
ultimately extradited to the United
States for uh plotting and planning
actually it was in the planning stages
it was start it was getting off the
ground when it was caught a a Jihad
terror training camp in
Oregon anyway Abu Hamza is now in prison
but his mosque is still operating in
London I went in there and uh I said I
understand you had some trouble here a
few years back and they said yes we had
some extremists here but now they're
gone and we're all moderates and so they
gave me this moderate Quran they were
trying very hard to convert me to
Islam anyway let's look at what the
moderate Quran says in regard to what
the Islamic State does the Islamic state
is first of all notorious for beheading
people and I have seen and maybe you
have seen articles because there's a
steady stream and an ever increasing
stream of articles that are explaining
to us and reassuring us that the Islamic
state is not Islamic has nothing to do
with Islam and we don't need to really
be worried about it because once the
Islamic state is eradicated by Barack
Obama's air Stripes unprecedented in
human history that a uh a territory was
conquered solely from the air but if
anybody can do it Barack Obama can and
when the Islamic state is gone then this
will all be over because they're the
only ones who think this Twisted
perverted thing that they do is
Islam unfortunately the Islamic state
has copies of the Quran too and so when
they open it up they see something like
this very straightforward when you meet
the unbelievers strike their
necks this is
47:4 so when they met the unbelievers
they struck their necks and then you
might say but wait a minute but Cas one
of the hostages and James Foley another
one of the hostages at least them and
possibly some others they all converted
to Islam the Jordanian pilate was
already a Muslim so why are they killing
other Muslims because you Spencer you
islamophobe you ought to know that 4: 92
of the Quran says that a Muslim must not
kill another Muslim so therefore because
they're killing other Muslims they must
not be Islamic
right well no not really see the uh
Islamic law has death penalty for
apostates in Heretics and so these guys
were fighting against the Islamic State
which they consider to be the caliphate
the only Earthly government to which
Muslims should properly give their
loyalty and so they figured these people
have rendered themselves non-muslim by
fighting against the Islamic State the
Jordanian pilot of course was flying
sores over the Islamic State so that
makes him an enemy Foley was in the Army
in Iraq so there you go doesn't matter
if they convert to Islam that doesn't
mean that you're you're you're all your
sins are forgiven that's Christian
baptism and I know that Islam and
Christianity are identical but
unfortunately there are just a few
details where they're not quite the same
thing and so even though they had
converted to Islam they couldn't be
forgiven and they had to be
killed what else do they do we know that
they have aroused the disgust and the
horror of the World by kidnapping
hundreds of women who were non-muslims
Christians and yazidis in Iraq and
pressing them into sex
slavery and people say well this is just
7th Century barbarism this is not
anything that any
civilized human being would ever
countenance and it couldn't possibly
have something to do with one of the
great abrahamic religions right so let's
go to the
book open your
qurans to
4:3 and you will see marry the women
that seem good to you
two or three or
four if you fear that you will not be
able to treat them justly then marry
only one
or the captives of your right hand
what's a captive of your right hand
slave a slave you are correct sir a
captive of your right hand is some is a
woman who is captured in battle this is
absolutely clear from another passage
3350 for those of you who are keeping
score where Muhammad
is told oh Prophet we have made lawful
for you your wives whose Bridal dues you
have paid got to pay the dues and the
slave girls you possess from among the
prisoners of
war the slave girls you possess from
among the prisoners of War well what are
those women in in in in the Islamic
State but slave girls they possess from
among the prisoners of War to make it
absolutely clear yet another passage and
I'm doing this I understand that it
might be tedious to do a little Quran
study here tonight but you have to
understand that these things when
they're not just mentioned once but
mentioned twice three times four times
in the Quran and actually there are four
passages having to do with sexual
slavery of kidnapped captured Infidel
women then you're talking about not
something that you can say well there
was some crazy verse they're weird
verses all over the Bible you know and
therefore we shouldn't be concerned
about this but actually this is
something that is that is important that
it's core it's mainstream it's mentioned
four times in this book which is shorter
than the New Testament the Believers
this is chapter 23 beginning of chapter
3 23 veres 1 to6 the Believers have have
attained have indeed attained true
success what is true success you ask
those who in their prayers humble
themselves sounds good how how very
judeo-christian to avoid whatever is
vain and frivolous who observe zaka
which is paying off so right now we're
all religions are the same same right
they essentially teach the same thing
here we are who strictly guard their
private parts pardon me but this is what
it says except from their wives or from
Those whom their right hands
possess so we have it abundantly clear
what these girls are
for now you can say yes but see this is
a book that is subject to all kinds of
interpretation and that's why I brought
this particular one along so that we
could get maud's interpretation
of these passages and the first one I
read about marry the women who see who
seem good to you two or three or four or
the captives of your right hand Mal Dudi
has a note on this and remember this is
an internationally renowned Islamic
scholar you can find his books in any is
go to islamicbookstore.com I'm sure you
have an account there and look for Mal
Duty you'll find it plenty of his books
he says that the captives of the right
hand he says this this expression
denotes slave girls I.E female captives
of War who are distributed by the state
among individuals when no exchange of
prisoners of War takes
place isn't that what they did exactly I
mean exactly remember maudi was in
Pakistan he died in 1979 he never heard
of the Islamic State he was not in Iraq
or Syria he was just reading the same
book other people read it too this is
the problem
when the Jordanian pilot was burned
alive in the cage there were many many
many articles that said well of course
this has nothing to do with
Islam that goes without saying because
Muhammad said do not punish with Allah's
punishment the punishment of fire in
other words Allah will cast us all into
hell he'll cast you all into hell for
listening to me tonight and he will burn
you with fire there but the human beings
are not to burn people with fire got
that
there's just a loophole though there
always
is Chap 2:
194 it says this if someone has attacked
you attack him just as he attacked
you now those of you who are in the
military can test if you drop bombs on a
place things catch
fire if the Jordanian pilate is dropping
bombs on the Islamic State he burned
things and so they burned him they
attacked him in the same way they were
attacked
QED there you
go another thing that they did when they
got to
mosul which was an ancient city in Iraq
where there has been a Christian
presence a significant Christian
presence since the time of Christ they
painted the noon which is the Arabic
letter N it looks like a well my kids
call it the the cyclop smiley because
it's kind of a smile or a bowl with it
one do over it not two like a smiley in
English it's anyway it's a noon and the
noon was painted on the doors of
Christian
homes it means it stands for Nara which
is the the quran's word for Christians
nazares why did they do this they did
this to Mark the people in those homes
for extortion or
death they did it in conjunction with a
konic command
the Quran says in chapter 9:29 fight
those who do not obey Allah and his
messenger and do not forbid what he has
forbidden even if they are of the people
of the book that is the Jews and the
Christians until they pay the gizia
which is a tax with willing submission
and feel themselves subdued so the
Islamic State went to these houses and
they knocked on the door and they said
you have to pay the
tax the tax that is a Hallmark of your
submission to the rule of the Muslims
and these were Christians who had lived
there and their families had lived there
for centuries and most recently they had
lived under Saddam Hussein in Iraq and
Saddam Hussein was a terrible guy but he
did not rule According to Islamic law
and he granted relative equal rights to
the Christians the Christians were not
paying a special tax for the privilege
of having not having their PL property
plundered and having themselves get
killed they were living with almost
relatively equal rights with the Muslims
in Iraq
but when the Islamic State came in they
said you have to pay the tax it's the
law they refused to pay the tax that
made them CER Hari infidels at war with
Islam and they had to be killed or they
fled from the area to avoid being
killed and people say well you see this
has nothing to do with Islam because
they lived there for centuries under
Islamic rule yes they did and they paid
the tax that in the 1850s Iraq was part
of the Ottoman Empire and the Ottoman
Empire under pressure from Western
powers in those days there were Western
powers and they said you have to stop
persecuting the Christians you have to
abolish the jiza the
tax and the Ottomans realized because
they were as you may recall from history
the sick men of Europe they realized if
we do not abolish this tax then we could
end up with British and French troops in
Anora and so we'll abolish the
tax contrast that to when we went into
Iraq and
Afghanistan and installed
constitutions under the egis of the
United States of America in both of
those countries that said Islamic law
Sharia would be the highest law of the
land which means we were saying go ahead
and collect the gizia and subjugate the
Christians and any other religious
minorities who were around go ahead and
take sex slaves who are captives of war
and all that go ahead and do all that
it's the highest law of the land and you
do that that's why I say in the those
days there were Western Powers you see
the
contrast there's the famous story about
the British commander who was approached
not by a Muslim but by a
Hindu when the British went into India
the Hindus had a practice of Sati which
was the wife would be compelled to or
would voluntarily throw herself onto the
funeral P of her departed
husband and the British
said that's against the law you're not
going to do that anymore a delegation of
Hindus went to the British commander and
they said you have to understand this is
our
culture and he said fine you go ahead
and live according to your culture we
too have a culture and our culture is
that when men compel women to throw
themselves onto a fire we take those men
and hang them by the neck until
dead so you live out your culture and we
live out ours
nowadays we put in constitutions in Iraq
and Afghanistan saying go ahead and live
out your culture and we will not live
out ours we will not stand up for our
own
principles and we will Aid you and give
you billions of dollars to enable you to
live out
yours and this is because of course all
cultures are the same all religions are
the same they all teach the same things
and they're all equally good and equally
beneficial for the human being in
individually and Human Society
collectively we all know that
right so let's take
another what is the Islamic State been
up to
lately are they working on Innovations
to win themselves Nobel
prizes have they discovered a cure for
cancer have they built hospitals and
schools no the Islamic state has been
busy have gone into the museum in mosul
and taken sledgehammers to 3,000 year
old artifacts of the Assyrian
culture and they went into
two ancient Assyrian cities nimr and hat
and they did the same thing they
destroyed all these ancient
archaeological works of
art that had stood there for thousands
of
years and people said said how Savage
how barbaric how terrible and how
totally un
Islamic because of course we all know
that as soon as anything like this
happens we uh know that our officials
who know so much about this will take to
the airwaves to assure us that it's not
Islamic and so this too is not
Islamic there's just one problem and
that is the
Quran the Quran says
this many many
eras have passed before you many eras
have passed before you go about then in
the land and behold the end of those who
rejected
Allah calling his directives
lies so what it's saying is go around
the world and look at the ruins of
ancient cultures and those ruins are a
sign of Allah's judgment on these people
because they rejected
Islam maheno daro is a very famous
ancient archaeological site it's in
Pakistan and there's been an ongoing
controversy for years now about whether
it should just be bulldozed and
forgotten or whether it should be opened
to archaeological exploration by Western
archaeologists and open to
tourism and then somebody hit on a
compromised position he said just put
the Quran verse that I just read to you
3: 137 many are the eras that passed
before you go about the world and see
the end of those who rejected Allah put
that as a sign in front of
the ruins at Mento daro in other words
the only value that ancient
archaeological artifacts have for
hardcore Muslims Believers in the Quran
is as ruins the only value they have is
that they're Rubble
and that the rubble shows that Allah
will eventually punish all those who
reject it you see so the the the ancient
Assyrian artifacts they were of no value
to the Islamic State as
such but as Rubble they're a great Val
so they had to make them into
Rubble they had to create them as
ruins because that is a sign that Allah
has judged
them and so what you have
here is a culture that loves
destruction that loves to ruin
things we saw it on
911 it wasn't just that they wanted to
weaken the United States but they wanted
to do it by hitting at one of the
foremost and iconic structures in the
city of New York and in the United
States as a whole
because they're
destroyers now see this is a totally
different mindset from that in the West
in the West in the judeo-christian
tradition creation is
valued and there's the idea of God as
the creator of all things now of course
Allah is supposed to be the creator of
all things but then he tells his
followers to go around breaking them up
again destroying
them but in the judeo-christian view God
created all things and he created human
beings and and he made them in His image
as creators who create
things and the things that human beings
create art and music and literature are
things that Inspire The Souls of other
human beings to create and also to act
in ways that are kind generous
magnanimous and good and those things
build up human societies and this is why
Western Civilization is the greatest
civilization on Earth because these
fundamental principles move
people form people in ways that are good
and that make for Life creativity
prosperity and then there are the
Destroyers a long not long after 911
there was a uh Taliban fighter
interviewed on
television and uh I think it was CNN and
he said
that he was absolutely certain that if
the United States invaded Afghanistan
that the Taliban would win and the guy
asked him why and he said the Americans
Love Pepsi Cola we love
death well I've never had a drink of it
so I'm not sure
but the Americans love pepsic colola we
love death is actually a konic
principle I know Pepsi Cola is not in
the Quran but the Death part is
tell them there's a lot of tell thems in
the Quran you know it's it's oh there
you got a Pepsi Cola so you must be an
American the uh the Quran is always
Allah telling Muhammad to say things to
the unbelievers so tell them oh you who
are Jews if you arrogantly fancy that
you are Allah's favorites to the
exclusion of all people then wish for
death if you were truthful in your claim
so saying if if if you Jews say that you
are God's chosen people then you have to
love death because that's what according
to the Quran God's people will do and
again and again we see this
from Islamic jihadis they say we will
win because we love death more than you
love
life now loving
death consider
that it all starts to fit
together loving
death loving
destruction loving
oppression loving
pain this is something that is
representing values that are absolutely
contrary to the values not just of the
judeo-christian west but of anybody who
loves life and values Life as a gift and
anyone who understands that life is good
that creation is good that to create
things is good that to love is good
rather than
to and so we are truly
in a
battle for our very lives not just in
the sense that they will kill us if they
can but in the sense that life itself is
being challenged that it is life versus
death you either love life or you love
death
creation versus destruction love versus
hatred that's what this is
about and so when we see the Islamic
State we see not only that they embody
Islam as I have explained here in
this that it's all in the Quran what
they do but also that they
embody what may be the foremost evil
force that the world has ever
seen the Soviet Union you know that was
the the Cold
War and I'm sure that most of us here
remember it very
vividly and how amazingly astonishing it
was when the Wall came down and the Cold
War of course went on for so many
years because of mut the principle of
mutually assured
destruction and the idea was that we
have all sorts of nuclear weapons
pointing at them they have all sorts of
nuclear weapons pointing at us we don't
want to die they don't want to die and
so we're in a standoff and we'll just
look at each other eye to eye for 30
years until one of us blanks and they
blank
blinked mutually ass short destruction
does not work in this
context if you got people who love life
then they will not want to die and so
they will be willing to make various
adjustments and even
concessions or at least to negotiate a
mutually acceptable
settlement so that you can both go on
and live in peace but people who love
death they got nothing to lose they want
to they want to get there the Boston
Marathon
bomber you remember jart sarv the
Rolling Stone cover boy he fled
when he after he'd run over his brother
and killed him and the police are
chasing him and he's running and he goes
into some guy's yard and into his boat
and he found a marker he had it on him
or something I don't know and he wrote
on the inside of the
boat and he wrote that we see Paradise
in the barrels of your
guns in other words go ahead and shoot
us because then we will go to paradise
Islam in the beginning was able to
conquer a huge expansive
territory starting out the Arabs
starting out in the
630s they conquered all of the Middle
East all of North Africa Persia went
into India by 732 which is 100 years
after Muhammad is supposed to have died
they control from Southern France all
the way across North Africa all the way
across the Middle East into Persia and
into India how did they do that they did
that because they created the most
formidable formula for a warrior Creed
that has ever been
developed chapter 8 of the Quran is
called The Spoils of War ala The Spoils
of
War and it dictates that if you go and
you capture various material Goods in
battle and those cap of the right hand
you give 20% to Muhammad and you can
keep the
rest so you have an incentive if you're
some poor guy trying to eek out a living
with some sort of a farm in the Sands of
Arabia and then you hear that you can go
and you can if you if you kill these
guys you can take all their
stuff you give away a fifth but you got
four
fifths women possessions money whatever
and if you lose what
happens you go right to paradise and in
Paradise there are 72
virgins ready to serve
you non-alcoholic
wine it's actually could be alcoholic
wine the scholars differ on that it says
that it's wine flowing in streams by the
couches on which the the blessed are
reining but it is
uh not intoxicating so I guess it's kind
of jeels or something or you know the uh
sparkling grape juice but
anyway it's
there and so you've got a win-win
situation if you win you enjoy The
Spoils of War if you lose you enjoy all
the material Comforts of paradise the
the the the paradise that you can
imagine would be paradise for a young
man in Arabia in the 7th Century he
thinks well what do I want most
girls lot of food shade it's a lot of
talk about shade and cool breezes in
Paradise wine sure bring it
on and so you have no way to
lose and this created a warrior class
that was
unbeatable and so they amassed this huge
Empire I actually
actually Bruce mention wrote a book did
Muhammad exist a few years back uh I
won't go into all the details about why
I don't think Muhammad was a historical
figure uh you can always read the book
but uh available in any self-respecting
book schore but the point um reason why
I bring it up tonight is
because there is no evidence that all of
those
conquests in at the time that they
happened
nobody there were a lot of people
writing down what happened particularly
the conquered people and nobody ever
mentions Muhammad or the Quran or Islam
or calls the conquerors
Muslims which is an extraordinary
Omission if Muhammad is supposed to have
been the guy who actually energized
motivated and inspired all this conflix
so anyway the point is this that what
seems to be the case from the historical
record is that the figure of
Muhammad and the details of his life and
the teachings of the Quran regarding
Warfare against
unbelievers were created precisely in
order to build that Warrior group that
would be
unbeatable in those days there were two
great Powers before the Advent of the
Arab Empire the Byzantine Empire which
was Christian the Eastern Roman Empire
and the Persian Empire that was Zoro
asri and I mention their religions
because religion was what held those
empires together in those days there
weren't parliaments there weren't
constitutions the thing that the empires
of those days did in order to create
Unity among the people and preserve
their domains was to mandate a common
religion this is why the early
Christians were persecuted in the Roman
Empire because they wouldn't pay they
wouldn't pay obeisance to the Roman gods
and the Roman gods the glue of the
state if you didn't pay if you didn't
worship the same gods and you weren't
really a citizen of the
state so by the time Muhammad and Islam
come along you have this Christian
Empire you have a uh Persian zoroastrian
Empire and they had actually slugged it
out they had fought a series of wars
with each other in the early 700s 600s
rather that uh exhausted them both and
the area around Syria Egypt all that was
nominally part of the Byzantine Empire
but they didn't have enough troops to to
staff it anymore these areas were wide
open right for the plucking and the
Arabs plucked them and they took this
huge area but then what did they need
they needed something to hold their
empire together so Islam was created as
a result of that
need now the point the further point is
that in doing that you have a religion
created by politicians and warriors in
order to preserve and strengthen an
Empire what kind of a religion would you
do would you make up if you were in that
position one that was martial
violent instilling the idea that it was
a great thing to go out and fight and
die for the state which was the same
thing as the religion as the Islamic
State keeps insisting of itself
today and so you have this warlike
violent Creed that teaches these things
and throughout history Muslims have
acted upon them there has never been a
place ever in history since the Advent
of Islam where Muslims went and there
were large numbers of non-muslims and
there wasn't
conflict ever anywhere there is not a
place around the world today where there
are Muslims and non-muslims living
together in large numbers large numbers
is the key word here because of course
in America we don't have this so much
but it's
coming where they non-muslims and the
Muslims live in peace there is always
conflict there is always conflict
because of the imperatives within Islam
to fight against the unbelievers and to
subjugate
them there is always conflict and yet
our leaders in the United States tell us
it's going to be different here the
Muslims here are moderate and they're
more assimilated and ithier than any
Muslims ever have been in the Islamic
world and so anybody who has any concern
about the fact that Barack Obama brought
300,000 Muslims into the United States
last year alone is just a racist figed
islamophobe and yet when we look at the
Quran the Quran is actually this is the
same Quran that Muslims read it's
written by Muslim in order to Aid
Muslims who don't understand Arabic it's
got commentary by a Muslim in order to
help those Muslims understand their
religion and it is the same Quran that
is taught in every American mosque in
every American Islamic school and the
same Quran that's everywhere there is
not an American denomination of Islam
that's different like the Catholics and
the
Protestants it's all the same Islam so
why do we think that it's going to be
different
here it's not and you can say well wait
a minute it is going to be different
here because they're already here and
and and for the most part we don't see
this
happening well there are as you may
know stages of development in the Quran
the Quran says a funny thing in chap 2
ver 106 it says when we agregate a verse
or cause it to be
forgotten we replace it with with one
that's just as good or better so Allah
reserves the right to cancel parts of
the Quran and give you better ones I
mean not now but back then when it was
being written now why would he do that
of course because because in shifting
circumstances you have to change the
teaching and so you make up an excuse
for changing the teaching from The
Immortal and immutable God now why does
that matter because in traditional
Islamic theology the violent passages of
the Quran supersede and agregate the
peaceful
ones however this doesn't mean people
have often asked me when I explain this
they say well wait a minute then why
don't they just take them out of the
Quran if they're cancelled because
cancellation is relative there are times
in which they kick in they just are not
valid for all time in the same way the
violent passages are I understand this
is a little bit abstruse what I mean is
this the verses that are aggregated that
are peaceful there are peaceful verses
in the Quran they're not really all that
peaceful but chapter 109 of the Quran
says for example say to the unbelievers
I don't worship what you worship and you
don't worship what I worship but
basically let's leave each other alone
you have your religion and I have
mine tolerance at least
the problem is that later on in
Muhammad's career he starts teaching
this violence and warfare as I explained
quoted some of them they slay the
unbelievers slay them wherever you find
them three times in the
Quran and so the passages that come
later are considered to have precedence
over the ones that come earlier however
when Muslims are in the same situation
that they were that replicates the
situation that Muhammad was in when he
got
the earlier passages the tolerant
passages then the the the situation is
the same those passages are once again
in
force I I don't mean to make this hard
to follow I try to make this very clear
that you have tolerance and then you
have the second stage defensive Warfare
and then you have the third stage which
is offensive Warfare Jihad to subjugate
the
unbelievers when Muhammad got the
tolerance versus According to Islamic
tradition he was a leader of a small
weak group of people they did not have
military power they did not have
political
power and so he preached tolerance it
wasn't tolerance for everybody else he
was asking the powers to be tolerant to
him when the Muslims are also weak and
do not have military power or political
power then they preach
tolerance in the United States we see
that now as they grow in strength then
the other parts kick in the defensive
Jihad and the offensive
Jihad and we are already seeing it we
will see more more of
It ultimately the objective is to
subjugate the entire world under the
rule of Islamic law once again Barack
Obama would tell me that I was a
terrible person for saying this and so
let's go to the Quran maudi explains
that verse chapter 9 ver 29 that I
mentioned before fight against those who
do not obey Allah and his messenger and
do not forbid what he has forbidden even
if they are of the people of the book
Jews and Christians until they pay the
gizia with willing submission and feel
themselves so subdued the Jews and
Christians have to be subdued to submit
to the hegy of the Muslims the word used
oop sorry wrong
place the purpose for which Muslims are
required to fight is not as one might
think to compel the unbelievers into
embracing Islam there's no forced
conversion you can still live as a Jew
or a Christian or a Hindu or whatever
rather its purpose is to put an end to
the suery the rule of the unbelievers so
that the latter are un able to rule over
people people the latter the unbelievers
are not supposed to be able to rule over
people not just the unbelievers are not
supposed to be able to rule over Israel
or Iraq or Afghanistan or whatever but
just people in general unbelievers are
not to rule the authority to rule should
only be vested in those who follow the
true Faith unbelievers who do not follow
this true Faith should live in a state
of
subordination anybody who becomes
convinced of the truth of is
May accept the faith of his or her own
valtion the unbelievers are required to
pay jiz pole tax in return for the
security provided to them as the demes
protected people of an Islamic State
gizia symbolizes the submission of the
unbelievers to the suar of
Islam so that's what the Islamic State
is about and of course finally the most
important piece of evidence that the
Islamic state is very
Islamic is the fact that over 20,000
Muslims from around the world have
joined it we never saw that with
Al-Qaeda we never saw that with any
other Jihad group there have been
several hundred Muslims from the United
States well over a thousand from France
a th000 from
Britain about 650 from
Germany 20,000
altogether now you understand this is
within the context of people saying oh
the Islamic state has nothing to do with
with Islam it's within the context of
the American Muslim groups saying we
denounce the Islamic State we condemn
the Islamic State all the Muslim groups
have condemn the Islamic State and yet
Muslims keep going
there and you got to wonder why is it
that if they condemn the Islamic State
have they so signally failed to explain
to their own young people why they
should reject the Islamic State if these
Muslim groups reject the Islamic State
why is there not a single mosque or
Islamic school in the United States
States or anywhere else in the world
that has a program to teach young
Muslims why they should reject the
understanding of Islam represented by
the Islamic State there is no such
program anywhere
why condemnation is easy but what we
don't see is any action from the Muslim
Community against the Islamic
State and that is because they know full
well the Islamic state is Islamic when
we see this steady stream of Articles
and steady stream of announcements from
Obama and K and everybody else that the
Islamic state has nothing to do with
Islam they have to keep telling us that
because it's so obvious that it's false
it's just the big lie repeated over and
over and if you repeat it over and over
people will start to buy it and so they
keep pumping it out the Islamic state is
actually broken through the fog of
disinformation they have kept up about
this issue for
decades and so they have to pour on more
dry ice to keep the fog thick
and the ultimate result of that will be
that we are absolutely ignorant and
complacent about the Jihad threat and if
you think about the people you work with
maybe the people in your family people
you know around from whatever activities
you're involved in I'm sure you know
that most Americans are ignorant and
complacent about the Jihad threat and
yet we have a mainstream media and a
government that seems intent on keeping
them ignorant and complacent about the
be hot
threat I uh won't speculate as to what
the goals are I well I yeah I
will there's one thing I think Barack
Obama you know people always ask Barack
Obama he's a Muslim right I don't know
he doesn't answer my emails he doesn't
return my
call but uh Barack Obama certainly grew
up a Muslim he was registered as a
Muslim in school he even says in his
first autobiography that uh he was got
in trouble for making faces in Quran
class class only the Muslim kids went to
Quran class he was a Muslim he says he's
not now okay fair enough the thing about
Barack Obama though is that I think that
he is most of all just a secular Marxist
and he thinks that if he gives the
islamics the uh the Islamic countries
not just the Islamic State if he gives
the Muslim world what it wants then
their grievances will be satisfied see
there's a funny thing
in Islamic law in Sunni Islam which is
85 to 90% of all Muslims only the Caleb
the successor of muhamad is the leader
of all the Muslims only the Caleb has
the authority to call offensive Jihad
remember that third stage that I
mentioned the final stage of jihad
Warfare in Quran only the caleff can can
call that but there's been no Cale since
1924 when the secular Turkish government
abolished the
caliphate there's one now over in Iraq
but nobody uh nobody accept them except
those 20,000 foreign Muslims and all the
other people but anyway there's no cff
so all Gad can only be defensive and
that means if you watch old Osama Bin
Laden videos or uh read any Jihad
literature they're always listing all
these grievances they're always whining
they're always complaining these guys
are the biggest cry babies on Earth and
they're saying you you did this to us
and you did that to us and we did you
did this and Israel and Iraq and and and
they have to strike that back but the
point is is that they are situating
themselves theologically within Islam as
as fighting a defensive Jihad they have
to because offens of jihad can't be
fought without a
Cale the goal of all the Jihad groups in
the world is to reestablish the calate
al-Qaeda doesn't like the Islamic State
because Al-Qaeda wanted to start a
caliphate and the Islamic State stole
their Thunder Muslim Brotherhood doesn't
like the Cal the Islamic State because
they wanted to start their own caliphate
and the Islamic State stole their
but the caliphate itself as an idea
that's what they all want so Barack
Obama I think he thought he would give
it to them not this one but the one that
the Muslim Brotherhood wanted and that's
why he was so favorable to morsy and the
Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt and he
figured they'll they'll get together
with Libya and Syria and start a
caliphate and then they won't have any
more Grievances and they'll go away and
they'll be
peace it's based on a fundamental
misunderstanding of Islamic theology but
we are in an era of fantasy based
policymaking where whole there virtually
the entire apparatus of American foreign
and domestic policy is based on false
assumptions anyway so the situation
given all this is indeed dire and I
can't sugarcoat it we have to know where
we are in order to get where we need to
be we can't pretend otherwise people
always say can't you end on a note of
Hope and I said if there were any I
would but there
is actually there is is and that is that
the truth will always out that they
can't help it they Soldier eaten used to
call it Blades of grass through the
concrete you can put concrete over the
grass but the grass will always spring
up in it and and break up the concrete
even though the grass is weak and the
concrete has all the
power we are facing a situation where
the government the media the educational
system the entertainment industry all
our leaders they're all clueless or
complicit or
both the only thing we have is the truth
they have to keep pouring on the fog of
disinformation as I said they have to
keep churning out all these false
articles about how the Islamic state is
not Islamic because people do know and
they are waking up and we can turn this
around because the truth cannot be
hidden and ultimately it's really a very
easy thing if we start demanding from
our elected officials and potential
elected officials that they speak the
truth about this and not accepting them
not doing so we could turn this around
really quite quickly I mentioned the
Berlin Wall in passing a while ago and
remember what a shock that was you know
right probably a year before that or two
or three years before that there were
still people saying in the western media
well you know the Soviet Union will be
dealing with them for centuries to
come and we're just going to have to
settle in for the Long Hall here and
then it came down so suddenly why
because it was B built on lies
and this culture this Cult of death and
destruction that loves death and loves
hatred and loves to destroy is also
built on lies and so it cannot possibly
win as long as we have the courage to
stand for the truth thank you
take questions at this
time what you should do is uh point out
that in Britain there are 75 sha courts
now and they've only been operating for
a few years at least
legally and a few years ago 2010
thereabouts when they were established
many many people in the British
government assured us that there would
be they would have nothing to do with uh
cases where Islamic law and British
criminal law contradicted each other
that those cases would be referred to
the criminal courts most notably you're
talking about spousal abuse because the
Quran says good women are obedient as
for those that are not give them a
warning send them to separate beds and
beat them uh that's 4:34 and so when a
woman would go to to a Sharia
court and say my husband beat me they
would say you better redouble your
efforts to please
him if she of course goes to the
criminal court then they're criminal
proceedings so those cases should have
been and we were would be referred to
the British Criminal Courts they were
not the Islamic courts dealt with many
cases like that many women therefore
were uh treated
unjustly and nothing has been done about
it
the promises were broken and it was
pretty much inevitable that they would
be but you can point out that Islam is
Sharia is an all encompassing system of
laws there is no distinction between the
parts of sharia that have to do with
Waging War against and subjugating
unbelievers and the parts that they
claim they're only going to be dealing
with like marriages and funerals and
such and that once you open the door to
the one you're opening the door to the
other and that Assurance is that there
would be some sort of a wall built up
between the aspects of sharia that are
compatible with American law with with
Western Law and the aspects that are not
this no wall was created and there was
no attempt to honor American law or
Western Law at all and so why will it be
different in Texas it won't
be you can also point out that there
were there was an attempt to bring
Sharia courts to
Canada that was defeated by a group of
Muslim women who knew what Sharia was
all about
and they came to Canada to get away from
it and all these things you know you can
find online very
easily Lewis how are you good how are
you good um my question is in regards to
the poor uneducated Muslims that are
convered into violence because of their
financial and Status what is the
financial status of is the uh Islamic
state is the richest terrorist group in
in the world they overran quite a few
oil wells as I said they control an area
larger than Great Britain and they have
about 60 oil rils and last report they
were getting $3 million a day selling
oil the uh Obama
administration sent John krey to Turkey
to ask the Turks to stop the Islamic
State from selling oil and the Islamic
State the the Turks said no
because see that's another one there's
so many people who want to calate uh the
another key person in the Islamic world
who wants to restore the caliphate is r
t beran the president of Turkey and he
of course turkey was the site of the
last caliphate the one that was
abolished in 1924 he wants to start it
again he's not a fan of the Islamic
State but I think he thinks he can use
it for his own ends that they can fight
his enemies the Kurds and others that he
hates and then he can go in and take
advantage of what they've done so he's
not going to stop them from doing
anything so in other words yes they're
very wealthy also survey after survey
has shown that Jihad terrorists are
generally wealthier and better educated
than their peers and so also there is
just a common sensical thing about this
it's been widely ridiculed of course you
know just give them jobs but think
about think about it that here's some
some guy who thinks that he is serving
God and some and he thinks that he is a
noble Warrior for the noblest cause on
earth and the US state department
actually thinks he's going to give that
up for a chance to say you want fries
with
that the the the idiocy is mindboggling
and yet these are the people who are in
charge who are making
policy yes sir okay if they only have 60
oil wells that they're they're surviving
on why we
bomb good
question address it to uh Barack H Obama
1600 Pennsylvania aveny no seriously
that's a very good question and a very
good point and why has it not been done
I think that because Obama does not
really want to do what needs to be done
to stop these
people he thinks that uh it seems clear
whether or not he himself is a Muslim
that he thinks Islam is great and good
for people and he certainly ate it and
Abed at itself spread in advance in the
United States and
elsewhere yes ma'am yes um what are your
thoughts on uh the Egyptian president CC
and even the King of Jordan I know the
Egyptian president spoke out about early
this year uh to a bunch of eons to we
need Reformation this Jihad has got to
be cut out and the other day I read
something about he shut down 27,000
mosque in Egypt what are your thoughts
that seems somewhat hopeful yeah he did
the president of Egypt AI he shut down
27,000 mosques King Abdullah of Jordan
has spoken out against the Islamic State
so has Ace aisi called for reform in
Islam uh these are all good things you
have to understand that uh aisi like
Mubarak and saddat and Nasser in Egypt
and like Saddam Hussein and like the
assads in Syria Ben Ali in tunia some
others they were Arab
nationalists and and the Arab
nationalist movement was a secular
movement it used to be up until like 20
years ago even maybe even 10 years ago
it was the most significant political
force in the in the in not in the whole
Islamic world but in the Arab world the
idea of a secular Western Government
essentially with some aspects of Islamic
law but not all of Islamic law
implemented and this was all over the
Middle East those guys were beasts but
they kept stability in the region such
that we wish we had there
now uh in the name of democracy we aided
and Abed at the taking out of many of
those regimes and there it was
inevitable that if you went for a oneman
one vat system that then there would be
put in Islamic regimes in these areas
and these of course are operating
According to Islamic principles and
wanting to reestablish Islamic law on
those countries Islamic law is not
enforced in full in Egypt or it hadn't
been in Iraq and in Syria it's not and
so on and so you have these people in a
peculiar position because Abdullah of
course and Jordan he's a Muslim but he's
not really a Hardline by the book guy
he's a Muslim culturally he's a Muslim
because this is the what he has to be if
he wants to be king of Jordan and AI is
the same way they do not you know I can
quote the book to them all day long and
they'll say yeah it's in there and I'm
not doing it there's a spectrum of
belief and knowledge and fervor among
all people in all religions and these
guys are not Hardline
Believers and so they want to the big
weakness of uh the Arab nationalist
movement was that it was made up
primarily of Muslims but it did not have
some alternate version of Islam that
said we shouldn't wake war against
unbelievers there is no form of Islam
that doesn't teach that so that put them
in a bad position they are trying he
called for AI called for the creation of
that kind of Islam and what's
significant is that not none of the
clerics to whom he was speaking at
alasar in Cairo heeded the call or said
yes we're going to do that we're going
to work on re-evaluating and reforming
all this and that was to be expected
because they know it's in the
book it was in other words it was good
that he said it but not really all that
great it's not going to change anything
yes
sir uh you're argument about 911 being
an internal war or a Muslim War
do you mean do I think the Muslims took
down the towers or did George Bush took
down the towers and some nefarious
scheme to get us involved in a war for
Israel no I believe the Muslims took
down the towers the uh uh KH Sheik
Muhammad the uh leading Mastermind of
the plot has freely acknowledged that
they cooked this cooked up this plot and
so on I don't think he's a CIA mole uh
the the idea of a president of the
United States committing an act of
treason on that scale
it just uh and also you know what else
just as a common sense thing a
conspiracy like that would have to
involve of necessity hundreds if not
thousands of people somebody's going to
talk but anyway I think that uh there's
plenty of motive plenty of wherewith all
plenty of money the will the power the
the desire to do it all among Muslims
why why uh try to make up anything else
yes sir going to be question you
probably answered it before but we
talked about with all due respect God
being a loving God creating God Etc
different from all yeah how do you
answer those critics who say look in the
Old Testament where God commanded to
Israel to go in and wipe out all the
people especially the Book of Joshua all
that kind absolutely uh there are
passages that are violent in the Old
Testament there is never a passage that
is violent in the Old Testament that
tells people to go out and imitate this
in other words the passages that are
violent in the Jewish scriptures
say they describe various things and
it's extremely problematic for both
Jewish and Christian e exites those who
are explaining the the scriptures it's
very problematic and difficult for them
because what they are most all
unanimously intent on doing is not
taking literal understanding of these
passages and emphasizing that they do
not apply to all people in all times and
places that they should be allegorized
understood in a spiritual way something
of various ways to emphasize that they
describe certain events but there is no
imitative cat uh imitative quality to
these descriptions in other words they
don't say Joshua emptied out a whole
city therefore you go and empty out a
city and no Jews or Christians have ever
committed acts of violence and said we
are doing this in Imitation of
uh Joshua or something written in
Deuteronomy or whatever and so that is
very different from what's in the Quran
which is prescriptive not descriped it
is prescribing behavior and saying the
you should wage war against and
subjugate unbelievers this is addressed
to all believers for all unbelievers it
is for all time there is no passage like
that in the Jewish or Christian
scriptures and so there's really no uh
comparison between the two uh there is
no imperative in any form of Judaism or
Christianity there is no theological
imperative to wage war against and
subjugate unbelievers and then you can
say oh but what about the Crusades and
so on the Crusades did not proceed
According to some sort of a doctrinal or
scriptural imperative they were a late
and defensive reaction to try to protect
the holy land after 450 years of jihad
Conquest had conquered over half of the
Christian world and after the uh Cale Al
hakeim in the Holy Land had destroyed
300,000 churches and the Church of the
Holy seer in Jerusalem and they the
Byzantine emperor had lost a major
battle of manre in 1071 lost all of Asia
Minor what is now turkey to to the
Ottomans and he appealed to help to the
pope this was what baked for the
Crusades in other words it wasn't them
saying we read in the Bible that we
should to kill and Conquer and therefore
we're going to kill and conquer the
Bible doesn't say that and they weren't
doing
it yes sir um what's the major
difference between the Shiites and the
sunnis and and why do they seem to hate
each other almost as much as they hate
us well they hate each other almost as
much as they hate us because they are
told that apostates and Heretics should
be
killed
um chapter 4:89
of the
Quran open your Quran to chapter
4 it
says they wish that you would disbelieve
just as they disbel so that you may be
all alike do not therefore take allies
from them until they immigrate in the
way of Allah which means become Muslims
like Muhammad immigrated from Mecca to
Medina and became the leader of a
community the leader of a military and
political force for the first time and
immigration became this holy thing in
Islam so they immigrate in the way of
Allah then they're okay but if they turn
their backs seize them and slay them
wherever you find them take none of them
for your ally or helper so he's say they
saying if you have people who become
Muslims and then they leave go and kill
them the idea that both the sun and the
Shiites have is that the other group has
done
that it started it's just a dynastic
dispute uh According to Islamic
tradition Muhammad died suddenly in the
year 632 according to the Shiites he
appointed his son-in-law Ali Tali to be
the head of the Muslim Community
according to the sunnis he did
not and they've been fighting about that
ever
since yes
sir Quan School stud the Quan all people
would know this is
is there possible not know yeah he might
not know that and this is why the Quran
is an Arabic this is not actually the
Quran I lied I said this was the Quran
it's an English Quran in Islamic
theology the Quran has to be an
Arabic if it's not an Arabic it's not
the Quran this is just the meaning of
the Quran now the meaning of the Quran
is all we need to understand it but for
a believing Muslim
he's got to recite the Quran in Arabic
if you were and I do not advise this but
if you were to convert to Islam
tomorrow then you would have to pray in
Arabic so you got to learn some Arabic
now it's a lot easier to learn to mouth
syllables than to learn a whole language
and so most Muslims today are not Arabs
most Muslims around the world today do
not speak Arabic and so when they learn
like in the Pakistan madrasas when they
go in and they learn they memorize the
Quran these 5 10-year-old War
they memorized the whole thing but they
had no idea what it's all about and I
actually had a few years back I was
talking to a Pakistani Muslim and he
said I'm very proud of my own religion
and I have memorized almost all of the
Quran and one day I'm going to get one
of those translations and find out what
it
says he had memorized a lot of Arabic
without knowing Arabic and it is
possible indeed likely that Obama in
Quran class memorized some Arabic
and that he I don't think he speaks
Arabic he might and he might know what
it means but he it's not an open and
shut case that because he went to Quran
school he would know all of Islamic
Doctrine because Islam is highly
ceremonial all you have to do is recite
the prayers in Arabic you don't have to
have any idea what you're
saying yes sir you mentioned um a
particular version here of someone
writing this particular Quran are there
different versions
that are interpreted different ways
there's only one Quran in Arabic there
are some minor variations the Shiites
have a couple of chapters they say they
don't but they do they have a couple of
chapters that the sunnis don't have but
there's nothing much interesting in them
and uh there are some variant among the
the the there's a manuscript tradition
in Africa that's different from the one
that most qurans come from it's just a
few minor differences of wording but
mostly it's all the same Arabic Quran
there are a lot of different English
translations and some of they all have
their weaknesses and they all have their
strengths I have 21 English translations
of the Quran in my office you know a
little light reading and uh
they mostly they're pretty much the same
but sometimes one of them will bring out
the meaning of a passage in a way that
another one obscures it there's a lot of
Quran translations that obscure the
meanings most the most popular ones are
written in this pseudo King James Bible
language with these and THS and I think
it's deliberately designed to aisc the
meaning so that people read things and
they fly right by them and they don't
realize what they're reading thank you
yes
sir we who are Christians we have in the
New Testament we have Snippets of the
New Testament we go back to the first
century that we have about 24,000
manuscripts of PR bringing place so we
have a lot of validity for the New
Testament that we have what kind of
validity is there for the Quran copy of
the Quran and how many years do that
come after the death of mam this is
where it gets really
weird I told you before that there that
the Arab armies came out of Arabia in
the 630s and by the 690s it conquered
all across the Middle East all across
North Africa in Persia and so on and yet
there is no mention of Muhammad the
Quran Islam Muslims nothing
from any of the writings of the people
at that
time and the standard story is in
Islamic tradition that the caleban the
third successor of
Muhammad he in 653 the year 653 gathered
together everybody who had memorized
parts of the
Quran and
he got them to write it all down burned
all the variants and distributed copy of
the Quran to the
provinces however there is no manuscript
from the
650s the uh weird thing is is that even
after that happened there's no mention
of the Quran from anym we don't hear any
mention of the Quran for another 40
years and so it seems unlikely that it
actually did exist at that time and then
in the 690s is when we start hearing
about the Quran and Islam and Muhammad
for the very first time the kaleth was
ABD Malik and ABD says a very strange
thing in one tradition he says I'm
afraid I'm going to die during Ramadan
because I was born during Ramadan I
became cth during Ramadan I collected
and codified the Quran during
Ramadan and so I'm afraid I'm going to
die during Ramadan now let me ask you
this why would anybody if they had the
Quran laying around for 40 years since
uthman who distributed to all the
provinces
remember why would anybody say that they
had done it 40 years later
but if he did it 40 years later then it
would make perfect sense for him to say
oh no this isn't anything new I got this
from MMA what you didn't get one oh here
you
go and of course there's no internet
they can't go and look on Wikipedia and
see if they really had this 40 years
ago and so he he he gives some an air of
authenticity to what he's done by
casting it back into the past but the
short answer is there no early
manuscripts there was actually recently
an early manuscript that was discovered
and there was some publicity about it
that it was dated from the 650s or 660s
and so I saw that coming along and I and
I thought oh well there goes my book and
my theory and you know that's it I'll
take up the saxophone but then I looked
at the they there was a full PDF of all
the manuscripts and it was fascinating
because this is supposed to be the
earliest manuscript of the Quran in the
first place there there's considerable
evidence that the Quran was made up from
material from other sources and so could
from one of those sources in the second
place you look at it and there's stuff
that's erased and written
over very good sign of things that might
be written by
committee together and so that's the
situation with the Quran we don't start
hearing about it as such until the early
8th
Century way in the back you've been very
patient thank
you theologically
speaking you studying you get the
feeling that you're reading actually two
separate religions two separate
scriptures with two separate
deities well I can't say is I ever have
actually no what what do you
mean uh the that
are
particular philosophy that
is is very different from the other
verses that are notated
yeah I see what you mean actually there
is a big difference in the Quran between
if you if you get a Quran even in
English you can tell this the uh
chapters from about 87 to to the end 114
are very brief very poetic with these
arresting
images just a few lines the
earlier parts of the book which actually
come later According to Islamic
tradition those are the medinan verses
that were uh revealed later excuse me in
Muhammad's career are long and ponderous
and uh not in the least poetic uh they
have a certain rhythm in Arabic but
nothing like the poetic character of the
earlier parts and so yeah I see your
point there that uh I think that what we
have here is a book as I said made by
committee and various Source materials
were put were drawn from and put
together and so people explain you know
Muhammad evolved in his poetic in his uh
prophetic career and his first
Revelations are very short and poetic
but as he became a military political
leader he had to issue directions for
The Ordering of the society and so they
became long and ponderous that's the
traditional view my view is they took
some bits from here and bits from there
and put it together to create a holy
book um even the word recitation Quran
is the name of a lectionary you know
there's still lectionaries in the
Catholic church and the Orthodox Church
the book where the readings Are all uh
put together it's not the Old Testament
or the New Testament as such but just a
series of the readings for every day
that will come up in the Liturgy or the
mass or what have you
and uh some people have posited that the
Quran is a lectionary like that that was
actually a uh Christian text combined
with some other Jewish texts and that's
why it flps from subject to subject and
doesn't have any logical or coherent
ordering because it was a lectionary for
different days and you know if you try
to pick up the book that's in the church
and read it through and think well I
just don't see the narrative flow in
this well it's because that's not how
it's organized anyway yes yeah I think
pretty much support what you just said
um as far as the U instruction of the
Quran as a committee work
as a Jewish student uh a lot of the
things that I see in the are DED from
mid Rush yes and they've all been
Twisted in the ways they not exactly the
same same number ver in the gospital of
Thomas
[Music]
well I don't think it's too different I
think that it's actually it's primarily
from Judaism and Christianity but it's
uh it's drawn from many different
sources I go through this in in my book
did Muhammad exist a lot of the things
some things even the The Paradise With
The Virgins comes from uh Zoroastrianism
although they don't have the same kind
of LD porous Paradise that nonetheless
it's uh and and so there there just a
lot of different things drawn upon but
yeah it is it does come from many
sources absolutely yes sir I was
wondering about the are starting to uh
oppose Isis is there some moderation in
bism or practical that they just want to
get this out of the way and the Saudis
are opposing Isis is that what you said
right yeah absolutely yeah the Saudis
it's it's sort of sweet uh revenge in a
certain sense it's kind of um poetic
justice is the word I was looking for
the Saudis are responsible for Isis they
created it they didn't create it
organizationally they created it
ideologically in in many parts of the
world partly because of the language
thing that I explained about how most of
the Muslims are just reciting stuff in
Arabic without necessarily knowing what
it means and ly because of various
cultural factors colonialism various
other things in East Africa Central Asia
other parts of the world there had
developed by the beginning of the 20th
century a form of cultural Islam that
was really rather benign not completely
benign but it certainly did not
emphasize Jihad and subjugation of
infidels then came the Saudi striking
oil and these guys with Untold billions
of dollars and what do they do
they give billions of dollars to
spreading Islam around the world their
understanding of Islam which is wahabism
wahabism was Islamic reform Muhammad IB
ABD wahab died in 1792 so he was roughly
a contemporary George Washington and he
taught that the Islamic establishment of
the Ottoman Empire the caith had grown
corrupt and straight from Islam and so
he was going to get back to the basics
to original Islam the Quran the Hadith
nothing else and absolutely literally
interpret these in the way that they
were intended and he that's
wahabism they spent billions spreading
that around the world saying the only
legitimate government is a caliphate now
they got a caliphate right next door
saying yeah that means your government
is not
legitimate it's just kind of sweet
really but um they did it and so they
oppos the Islamic State because they're
threatened by it no theological grounds
whatsoever as a matter of fact they
created they didn't create the
theological grounds but they emphasized
and spread everywhere the understanding
of those theological grounds that made
for the creation of the Islamic
State uh let's see yes sir what do you
say to the incoherent view that we get
in this country that Islam is peaceful
but then when pushed you hear people say
well we need to help reform it because
there's so many moderate Muslims well
there are plenty of moderate Muslims the
question is what is a moderate Muslim
the United States government thinks that
you're a moderate Muslim if you're not
strapping on a bomb b
but the idea is the assumption that they
have is that a moderate Muslim is
somebody who thinks we shouldn't wage
war against unbelievers we shouldn't
conquer non-muslim States and islamize
them there are no mod Muslims like
that there might be some who think that
we shouldn't do it but if they are aware
of what's in the Quran they're not going
to stand up to those
who are fighting thats will battles
they're not going to stand up because
they know what's in the Quran there are
people who are identified as Muslims who
are ignorant of what's in the Quran and
so they're not fighting to conquer us
because they don't know what's in there
but when the conflict worsens will they
side with us unlikely they'll probably
side with the Muslims because they
identify themselves as such there are
Muslims who just can't be bothered who
are just like anybody else you know
nominal Christians and people who are of
any religion but just aren't that into
it and there are Muslims who are like
that they'd really just rather work
their jobs and have a family you know
human nature is everywhere the same
Muslims aren't any different from
anybody else so there are Muslims who
just don't care they know that's in
there but they don't
care if you really want reformers who
say we have to reject Muhammad as an
example and reform the violent passages
of the Quran evolve a new understanding
of them that mitigates their capacity to
incite people to
violence zi
jasser um asra nanii you know maybe five
of
them yes sir what do you think of our
current C
director
well on October 19th 2011 57 Muslim
organizations Muslim South Asian and
Arab organizations wrote to John Brennan
he was then in homeland security and
he's now the of course the CIA director
and they demanded that I be fired from
training FBI
agents and demanded that all
counterterror training materials be
scrubbed of any mention of jihad and
Islam in connection with
terrorism Brenan wrote back on White
House stationary do you think he ran out
of paper and went to the Oval Office and
said hey Barack can I bar a piece of
paper no he was emphasizing that this
was from the top this was the highest
level and he said absolutely we're going
to comply we will not only comply we
will
re-educate any of the agents who have
been trained by these islamophobes or
these islamophobic
materials and so ever since October 19th
2011 or whenever it was that Brennan
answered shortly after
that if you in the FBI if you're in the
CIA you're in homeland security you're
not allowed you're forbidden as a matter
of policy to understand the motives and
goals of the
enemy
and you might you know it's not that
dire because I know they're plenty of
agents who go out on their own and they
find out and they study on them but if
you're in the agency and you're going to
get in a speaker who's going to tell you
about Islam you might but he'll tell you
all about how it's
peace and that's Brennon
but it's really Obama and of course then
there are the rumors and I don't really
think they're rumors I think it's it's
pretty much open and shut and I tell you
that because when I used to train FBI
agents I was brought in by an agent John
guondo who you may have heard of John
guondo has left the bureau but he says
that when he was there it was an open it
was open knowledge it was I I was going
to say an Open Secret but it wasn't
really in any sense a secret everybody
knew that when Brennan had served in
Saudi Arabia he converted to
Islam and that he was a practicing
Muslim now and that the uh there was a
big New Yorker piece about the one of
the leaders of our
counterterrorism uh strategy efforts was
a Muslim and the he was not named in
that piece but that it was BR and I have
no reason to think John guondo I know
John guondo John guondo is a friend of
mine and you're no no sorry John gondo I
don't think he would be lying about that
I just don't see him as that kind of guy
I was on Wikipedia I got this video
somebody sent me an email with a video
from YouTube showing this guy
talking recite you know in Arabic you
know Islam that but the thing is s
research we and before
I with P the religious backgrounds of of
positions of
power they don't have that anymore did
you see the movie I think it was Zero
Dark 30
yes uh the Brennan's in there as a
Muslim I mean it's clearly Brennan and
he's clearly a Muslim the GU somebody
one of those agents goes into his office
and he's getting up from
his you know his prayer rug uh and and I
I mentioned that it's just a movie but I
mention that because remember the Obama
Administration got in some trouble for
uh leaking classified information to
those Movie Makers and so for them to
have a very high level Counter
Intelligence counterterror guy be Muslim
you know I think they know something yes
sir how about
Valar she Bor in IR she a Muslim as far
as I know she was born in Iran and
that's where it stops you know this is
another one of these mysterious people
in the Obama Administration about which
we know so little definitely communist
well all the people around them are
communists you know he's a communist but
communism and Islam people might say you
know people often do say how is it that
these uh how can communism and Islam be
compatible it look they're eminently
compatible and they never had any
trouble in the in you know Christians
were persecuted in the Soviet Union Jews
were persecuted in the Soviet Union the
Muslims not so much in uh the the Soviet
republics that are now independent
countries usbekistan Tajikistan Kyan
Kazakhstan went out
turkistan and uh and my uncle Stan um
but
anyway it's because they both have a
totalitarian authoritarian gr View and I
think this is why the left and Islam
gets along so well together they both
want to silence descent you know
leftists will never discuss never debate
they just want to shut you down and of
course Islam forbids criticism of
Islam
and the uh idea of a reign of terror
every time Communists had come into
power there was a Reign of Terror in
other words they would kill a lot of
people to serve him as example for the
both those who they didn't kill that
they better not get out of line same
thing in Islam it's a slow motion reign
of terror Sharia is a reign of terror
you know stonings and amputations and
all that it keeps people in fear all the
time so they won't get out of line it's
the same thing so I think they're kind
of Blood Brothers really yes sir some
that the scent that you say
is trying to be dismissed I I like to
call it the the acceptance of uh The
Twist of diversity of political
correctness it's so part of our it's
part of our culture now I mean workplace
violence of Ford hood and and Isis are
not terrorists I mean is this to protect
us from uh going to another full-blown
Crusades or is that the bottom line or
what I think that the idea is to
intimidate people into thinking that
there's something wrong with resisting
Jihad Terror and that's the work of
people who obviously want Jihad Terror
to
succeed and like I say I'm not uh I you
know I don't really know what is behind
all this I think bar Barack Obama
probably thinks that he really will
bring around peace bring about peace in
the world by granting them all their
grievances uh around but the political
correctness when you talk about that and
the denial the willful ignorance about
all this it's deadly you know it's not
just that people are afraid to talk talk
about this in in in in an honest fashion
it's not just that our political leaders
are afraid to name the enemy it's that
the refusal to name the enemy has become
as you pointed out a culture-wide
phenomenon and people are afraid to even
discuss it honestly and that is deadly
I'll give you an example did you do you
remember the Fort Dicks plot it wasn't
not Fort Hood but Fort Dicks uh in New
Jersey isn't it and there were these uh
six Albanian Muslims remember the their
Albanian cuz it's important later and
they were going to drive into Fort Dicks
and shoot as many American soldiers as
possible and then get shot and go and
have the
virgins the plot was foiled how was it
foiled there was they they had all these
gory Jihad videos blood beheadings Gore
explosions they loved all that stuff but
they had it on VHS tapes so they took it
to a video store and there's this
17-year-old kid behind the counter and
they say we convert these to DVD for us
and he said okay you know he's there
working and he's seeing all this
horrible stuff go by and he realizes
that something may be up here so he goes
to his manager and he said you know how
these kids today are he's like
dude I'm seeing some really weird [__]
on these videos
should I go to the police or would that
be
racist should I go to the police or
would that be racist remember they were
albanians they were all white
guys but anyway he had internalized the
idea that it would be racist to resist
Jihad
Terror and he was 17 he wasn't
reading the the newspapers or watching
the news he just breathed this in with
the cultural ER luckily he decided to be
racist in the
plot yes sir in the back yeah I I
TOS now
I is a
Muslim I'm okay with a man being a
Muslim
but I really have paid attention since 9
happen how many people
well the thing about it is is that it's
never been spoken about about at all the
people in this room have heard about it
because they have heard John vono say it
somewhere or heard me say it somewhere
or heard somebody else repeating John
gondolo or me but it has never been on
like ABC or CBS or NBC no reporter has
ever gone up to Brennan and say do you
have any comment about this it just lays
there un UND with and this is what
always happens you know these people
don't feel as if they have any
accountability they don't have to
address these things and you know it
doesn't really matter you're right if
John Brennan's a Muslim depending on
what that in does to his ideas of what
ought to be done about the G Terror
threat and Brennan has said he's on
record many times saying Jihad is benign
it's the struggle in the soul to better
yourself and Jihad is a wonderful thing
the problem is when we have terrorists
who are saying they are waging Jihad he
is hampering he is hindering our ability
to understand the enemy that to
formulate ways to counter his ideology
when he says that and that's why it
matters 911
as biger deal as World
War country world and it seems like if
say in the
earlys if you had a person in government
that of
change after 91
in agency
direct that needs to be known it needs
to be known but there's a big problem
between your analogy of the ' 40s and
now and that's Joe
McCarthy and now whenever somebody says
you know like Michelle Bachman that
there are Muslim Brotherhood
infiltrators in the US government we
hear
McCarthyism and it's shut down YPO facto
with no examination as if because people
were falsely accused at some time in the
past therefore anybody who's accused of
something nefarious must be falsely
accused it's a ridiculous premise but it
rules the day yes ma'am yes um your
thoughts I was uh and I think many this
room would be impressed with uh prime
minister BB who came last week and spoke
at least open there it was I can't say
how well done that speech was your
thoughts on maybe that getting a lot of
people more aware of danger of Iran
getting the bomb they they're out to
kill us and and they just said it a week
before they're going to wipe Israel off
the map and we're the great Satan and
we're next this is Raising awareness is
the big problem because we don't have
any media
outlets and
so that's why we have the internet we
can thank God for the internet and
that's why they're trying to control the
Internet it's the only place where the
truth is getting out in full and so you
know it's pretty soon that's going be
over if they if it's not
stopped yes ma'am what do you think is
going to happen in 2016 with the new
president depending on who it is um and
with a couple of the Front Runners how
will this all this change in 2016 I
don't see it changing much in 2016 I'm
sorry I I I wish I could bring uh
sunshine and optimism but if you want
unicorns get John carry um the fact is
that the Republicans are just as out to
lunch on this issue as the Democrats
Grover norquist the head of Americans
for tax reform is a very powerful person
in the Republican Party nobody can
really get elected to a significant
offense in the Republican party without
having him support him the candidacy and
Rover norquist is in close
collaboration with people like
abdurahman Alami abdur rman Alami is now
in prison in the '90s he was the leading
moderate Muslim he was the head of the
American Muslim Council which has now
been shut down and uh he was very
influential in Washington he uh wrote
checks to NorQuest for NorQuest
organizations and he is now in jail for
financing
Al-Qaeda norquist has other unsavory
associations of his kind and has uh
worked at for example he controls the
conservative political action conference
CPAC in Washington he's uh worked to
keep out any uh discussion of the Jihad
threat for years now out of CAC and so
uh the Republicans aren't going to get
anywhere with this unless that changes
or unless a mavick a renegade candidate
is elected what do you think the
situation is going to look like in 10
years in 10 years would do you remember
uh you remember Rocky
3 Rocky 3 was the one uh with Mr T you
know remember the guy with the
Mohawk and Mr T was a really bad guy and
they asked him what's your prediction
for the fight and he that's right my
prediction
pain in 10 years I think it's I'm sorry
to say I think it's going to be worse
because how could it not be you have
hundreds of thousands of Muslims coming
into the country with absolutely no
effort made to determine whether they
have Jihad sentiments or not do you have
children yes what are you tell them I
tell them all this and tell them they
have to
fight the thing is it's never over till
it's over and as long as they're free
people standing then I'll be standing
with them and I hope you will be
too and like I say the Berlin Wall shows
us things can turn around quickly but
right now we are not at that turn around
and I don't see it coming nobody saw the
burlin w coming either I think lies and
empires of Lies like that can and do
fall very quickly and so I I actually am
confident that that can happen but it's
not happening what I see is with the
increased immigration with the poorest
borders with the efforts by Muslim
groups to shut down counterterror
efforts because they're islamophobic the
New York City cops had a a program of
surveillance of mosques it was shut down
under pressure from Muslim organizations
who are allied with the new
mayor I mean how long can we just keep
doing things like that and think
nothing's going to
happen yes
sir I I I just see all the irony number
one after 911 when you were working with
uh education of the feds did you ever
work with uh Michael Resnik uh training
the FBI tearing down the Walls they
named that and this is why I think is
ironic is they named the new
anti-terrorism center in in DC after him
after his death and yet they've gotten
disassembled he tore down Jamie Jamie g
g wall well from what I understand
that's back up the agencies don't share
all this information we've had the
federal agent former federal agents here
talking to us that like you said don't
know didn't know about Jihad yeah they
don't and the goals so it's all been
disassembled and yet we built an
anti-terrorism Center DC it's like it's
not to long the national
counterterrorism Center yeah yeah I was
there yeah from Michael res yeah I spoke
uh to a group there if I recall
correctly I might be conflating two
different things but I think that I went
there with Steve Emerson and uh we did
an all day seminar he did four hours in
the morning and I did four hours in the
afternoon and it was a mix of FBI and
CIA agents and the first question from
these guys was you know you guys keep
ragging on care the Council on American
Islamic relations I depend on those guys
how can you be have such a Negative view
of them that's where we are and that was
like 8 years
ago so who did they study in that set
they study people that the uh groups
like care tell them to study so they say
you want to know about Islam go to John
Esposito who is a Saudi funded academic
who wrote a book called the Islamic
threat myth or reality and his answer is
of course
Smith and so they are in other words
completely uneducated and miseducated
about the threat yes sir uh Obama was
supposed to bring in 2,000 Syrian
refugees what's the chance that not is
is going to
infiltrate as many is people into that
2000 Group Well I think about 100% I
mean if you were that you try that's my
opinion also I mean it's just common
sense you know they have an opportunity
they take it they're not
dummies yes sir what do you think going
to
happen Israel and
Iran uh no doubt that these many
genocidal statements from
Iran from many different people indicate
that if they get a bomb though mus
it and you have to understand Shiite
esy the sun Shiite
split didn't you ask me about the sun
she split was me okay I knew it was from
around
here the Sunni Shiite
split is on the basis of who gets to
lead the Muslims and the Sunni idea is
it's the best man from the community
who's called the successor or kaleth the
Shiite idea is that it is is the Imam in
Sun Islam the Imam is like your local
Rabbi or local Parish priest he's the
guy down at the local mosque but in sh
Islam the Imam is the successor of
Muhammad who has some of his prophetic
character he's infallible and he is uh
almost a quasi new Prophet himself and
he has to be a member of Muhammad's
household he has to be a relative so
there was Ali and then there were 11
more and then the 12th one because he
has to be a member of Muhammad household
it becomes like a hereditary Dynasty
like a kingdom and so the 12th one was 5
years old in the year
874 he fell down a well and
died but in the
Shiite view he didn't die he's in the
well and he's
hidden and he's going to come out when
the Muslims are persecuted more
ferociously than they have ever been
persecuted
before now there have been mulas in Iran
who have said
that they understand that to mean if the
Muslims are persecuted more ferociously
than they've ever been persecuted before
they can bring on the
persecution of the Muslims by they send
an nuk to Tel Aviv 6 million people are
killed and Israel is destroyed Israel or
America or both retaliates 10 15 million
Iranians are killed the Muslims are
persecuted worse than ever before but
the Iranians can sustain that and the
12th Imam will come out of the well and
Conquer and islamize the world so
there's a no lose situation
again I think we have time for one more
question please any
more I can give a comment I know this
may not be popular but um I think we got
a defensive strategy here and I'm going
to quote George Batton the best defense
is a good offense we got the gospel just
preach Jesus wherever they're at I've
got a lot of Muslim Students in front of
me every day a lot of them don't seem to
have any idea of what you're talking
about they're just they don't they're
perfect to talk to they ask questions
and yeah I'm going to preach to them
they're not my heartbeat that the
Chinese are but I would just say preach
the gospel and don't worry about what
happens well the thing is of
course if we think about a billion
Muslims a billion three a billion six I
think probably a billion is more likely
number but in any case it's unlikely
that they're all going to convert to
anything else
and obviously a large scale War would be
catastrophic for Humanity but I think
that above all we do have to stand for
our own values as I was explaining in
the talk that when the British Empire
was strong enough to say yeah follow
your culture and we'll follow ours and
hang you for following yours then these
the the the Hindus stopped doing the
Sati and if we were to stand in the
Muslim countries and say anybody who is
wants to leave Islam and wants
protection from anybody who wants to
kill you come we'll give you Safe Harbor
and anybody who is beaten in your home
and you want to get away from the
husband who beats you come here and
we'll give you Safe Harbor and we stand
for freedom of speech freedom of
conscience equality of Rights of all
people before the law women as well as
men non-muslims as well as non-muslims I
think we'd have a lot of people in those
countries who would join us because
Human Nature is everywhere the same and
there are a lot of people who would say
they would much rather live under such a
system than under Islamic law we're not
givance look at them now what's that
that's why we went to Iraq no it isn't
we installed Sharia in
Iraq we never said we would protect the
hostage from Islam we never said we
would protect women who were threatened
never stood up for our own principles at
all that's what I'm saying we got to do
a